[Music]
we have always wanted to control other
people's minds so what if we told you
that you could have that power too
simply by watching this video you'll
want to stay tuned until the end to make
sure that you are better at this than
any of your friends you don't want to
miss the trick that will make people
happy to serve you if you love
psychology as much as we do don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we're showing you
10 psychology tricks that work on
anybody make people believe in your lies
we always need to lie a little bit
sometimes and it doesn't have to be
about telling your partner that we are
not cheating on them when we are
actually seeing someone else
sometimes we just don't want to go to an
event and we need a good reason to say
no to a night with our friends and if
you want to make sure that your lie
doesn't sound ridiculous and that you
don't start laughing for no reason you
will have to be a good liar one good
thing you can do is tell them something
embarrassing for example if you don't
want to go to your friend's sleepover
act a little shy and say that you have
night terrors and that you don't want to
wake up everybody they probably won't
insist and they will feel uncomfortable
asking any other question but make sure
that your story makes sense because if
you don't know what night terrors are
and always say that you sleep well they
will understand that you are a liar the
best thing to do is to stay as close to
the truth as possible so you'll even be
able to prove some things for example
you might have had night terrors when
you were a kid but you don't have to say
that you don't have them anymore
but there is still away they could find
out that you're lying hey guys we are so
excited to announce we are producing our
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup acts and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it and be sure to
let us know what you think in the
comment section we love to hear from you
make someone tell the truth we should
avoid lying as much as possible telling
your friend that you just don't sleep
well when you're not at home is a better
way to avoid a sleepover but what if you
are the one who is planning a sleepover
with your friends and one of them tells
you that they can't be there because
it's their dog's birthday there are
still some things you can do to make
them say the truth you
can stare at them without saying a word
to make them feel uncomfortable they
won't like the silence and will probably
try to say more and more things until
they get to the truth but if it doesn't
work you will have to act like a real
psychologist and not a bad cop adopt a
sincere and understanding tone try to
understand the reason why they did
something instead of accusing them for
example you can say that everyone feels
uncomfortable sometimes and you would
understand why they would say that
they're busy just to avoid an awkward
moment minimize the seriousness of the
situation so they will feel like they
won't have to face too many consequences
if they tell the truth being a good
friend is the best way to know
everyone's secret but make sure that you
stay a good friend after that or they
won't want to tell the truth anymore
make someone trust you this is one of
the most popular tricks to make people
like you you might be doing this without
even realizing it but once you
understand how it works you can have the
control of any situation mirroring is
really simple you are the mirror and you
have to copy the person in front of you
don't always do the exact same thing at
the exact same time keep it natural and
slowly take the position that they have
or do something that they did before in
the conversation you can try to copy
their body language their gestures their
facial expression their vocal pitch and
tone their body orientation and more
researchers from New York University
even prove that this chameleon effect
makes people like you the reason why it
works is that it makes us look connected
and engaged we also tend to trust people
more who look like us you are often
doing it without even thinking about it
but it can also help to know what you're
doing it is the perfect thing to do on a
date during an interview or if you want
your parents to trust you looking at
your crush to see if the acts like you
is also a good way to know if they're
interested in you we know that you want
to try this right now but watch this
video until the end if you want to learn
more tricks make people reveal who they
like if you want to know who likes you
the answer is in their smile and you'll
clearly see it when they laugh those who
laugh together stay together and this is
why you want to pay attention to people
who have the same sense of humor we know
that you mostly want to know who has a
crush on you so we'll start with that
one try to tell them something funny if
they easily smile or even laugh it may
be a sign that they're interested in you
keep talking to them and if they
think that you are so funny it is a good
opportunity to ask them on a date but if
they barely smile they will probably
just say that they're already dating
someone or they're busy even when you
are in a serious relationship a lot of
studies have shown that laughing is what
makes people stay together by looking at
couples they understood that shared
laughter was an indicator of greater
relationship quality that might not
surprise you so we also want to help you
understand who likes you if you are in a
group tell something funny and look at
everyone when they're laughing they will
look at the person that they liked the
most in the group if two people are
looking at each other it might be a sign
that they are in love you'll definitely
try it make people feel closer to you we
found a magic trick to make people feel
closer to you even if you just see them
for an hour this is a great way to meet
new friends or even feel more connected
to your crush and the best thing is that
anyone can do this small talk is not
really interesting for anyone as it is
only a way to waste your time instead
try to tell your secrets to people we're
not saying that the first thing you
should tell someone is that you stole
your sister's favorite doll when you
were a kid but you can slowly start
talking about things that are more
personal during a conversation in the
study at the Stonybrook University a
researcher found out that people felt
closer to each other after spending only
45 minutes together
when they asked each other questions
which got deep and personal and the more
you reveal things about you the more you
will know about that person and you will
feel like you share something special
this gives us a great idea for a date
right a lot of questions that you would
like your crush to answer on different
pieces of paper or you can also just use
all the questions from a truth or dare
game you will quickly feel more
connected and you will be able to ask
your crush the most important question
who do they like make people like you
you might think that you have to be
perfect to make people like you
but it is actually the opposite having
some flaws is what will make people like
you even more we don't say that you
should be a terrible person that
everyone hates but making little
mistakes sometimes is actually a good
thing that's because people will like
you even more after you make a mistake
only if they already think that you're a
competent person that's called the
pratfall effect and the reason why is
really simple it simply makes you more
relatable and vulnerable toward the
people around you after all aren't you
in
intimidated by your crush when you think
that they are too perfect we all felt
like we are not good enough at some
point in our lives but then you learn
that they are bad in science class and
you know that you can do something to
help them this is also what makes clumsy
people really cute and that's something
you can work on if you want people to
like you we are not saying that you
should fall from your chair just to get
people's attention or look desperate
but don't be shy to talk about some of
your flaws sometimes and you'll be happy
to hear that the others are not perfect
either life would be boring if we didn't
make any mistakes make someone fall in
love with you all these things are great
but how can you make sure that someone
who likes you will love you a little
more on the first date there is one
trick that works almost every time
mostly if you're dating a girl if you
want to make them feel something give
them adrenaline this is why watching a
horror movie on a date is a great idea
social psychology experiments prove that
people miss attribute feelings of fear
and anxiety to feelings of love their
palms are sweaty and their heart is
racing which makes them more aroused but
when they try to think about what makes
them feel this way they look close to
them and they see their date this is why
they think that this person makes them
feel this way and it is probably love it
sounds crazy but scientists actually
proved it during an experiment but they
were surprised to see that men didn't
really react to that even though they
were a little bit more aroused but it
was crazy to see how women were feeling
when they were watching a horror movie
and it doesn't only work with movies you
can also try to go on a roller coaster
instead of the ferris wheel living an
adventure together is also a great way
to have more adrenaline so you know what
to do next time you want to go on a date
make people lose at rock-paper-scissors
you might think that it's impossible to
cheat at rock-paper-scissors there is no
way to guess what the other person is
going to do right but you would be wrong
that's because psychology is the best
thing that will help you win scientists
from China studied this game and they
came up with the best way to win you
will lose the first round but you can
guess what is going to happen after if
the player wins they will usually stick
with the same clay but if they lose they
will usually try another action usually
the next one on the list so if they lost
with rock they will try paper and so on
if you are playing three rounds of
paper scissors you're going to have a
lot of chances to win however you will
have to think fast other players have
many other tricks some use pattern
recognition of the other players moves
to understand what they're going to do
next
others say what they are going to do
like throw paper and the opponent thinks
that they are not stupid enough to do
that but the player throws paper anyway
you can also look at the other players
hand if the thumb is already tucked in
the crook of the index finger they will
probably use the rock keep playing with
your friends and you'll learn more
things with a little bit of practice
make people give you what you want we've
all been there mostly when we were kids
we wanted to ask our parents to give us
something but our father told us to ask
our mother and our mother said no and
even as adults we asked them to help us
pay for our new car or a new house but
with these tricks you will have more
chances to get what you want from your
parents or anyone who could help you one
of the best things you can do is ask for
something really expensive you know that
they will say no but that's not
important you can then ask for something
that you really want and it will look
more considerable compared to the first
thing you ask for example you can ask
for a horse and if your parents say no
ask for a dog but just make sure that
you also like horses just in case they
say yes when you ask moreover every time
that you get something show your parents
that you really appreciate it this will
make them want to give you more things
the next time you ask another way to
deal with them is to offer something in
exchange for what you want them to give
you or you can also try to use a little
bit of your money to pay for something
and ask them that they can help with the
rest your parents are not that bad after
all
make people your servants did you know
that you can make people do things for
you and make them like you at the same
time it seems too good to be true but we
can tell you that it is actually a dream
come true and it is called the Ben
Franklin effect you simply need to ask
people to do a little something for you
don't ask a stranger to loan you $10,000
but you can ask your friend if they
could help you do your homework or
babysit your dog for example you might
think that the person helping you will
think that you're annoying but you will
be surprised to see that they will like
you even more what happened to Benjamin
Franklin is that he had a hater but
instead of acting like him he decided to
ask him if he could borrow a book
the man was pleased and Franklin
returned it one week later with a
thank-you note since that day they had
been friends and it was proven by
researchers at helping someone and
hating them doesn't go together so our
brain makes us think that we like them
instead others also think that the
person simply understands that you want
to be their friend so they act nicely
anyway this trick works are you gonna
try any of these tricks if you do don't
be shy to tell us what happened in the
comment section down below we love to
know what you think and that's it for 10
psychology tricks that work on anybody
for more stories like this make sure you
watch five foolproof ways to spot a liar
thanks for watching
[Music]